now there's a reason i like kate
mckinnon and i have so much respect for
her as a talent
she's so even-handed in their political
commentary fox news host laura ingram
reacts to kate mckinnon's impressions of
her on saturday night live good evening
i'm laura ingram and as soon as i marry
your dad i'm sending you straight to
boarding school
but she's not the only one
candace owens has some thoughts on her
impersonation too martin luther king
would have voted for trump
hello to you too
but first let's get back to laura over
the weekend snl's cold open featured
kate's most recent take on the
conservative tv personality
well we're finally done with year one of
biden's presidency and can we all admit
it's a disaster
inflation's out of control
gas is at 19
a gallon
and the green m m has been cancelled
just for being a [ __ ]
it didn't take long for laura to see the
bit so at the close of monday's the
ingram angle the connecticut native
offered up her best impression now
there's a reason i like kate mckinnon
and i have so much respect for her as a
talent
she's so even-handed in her political
commentary but seriously
think of all the low-hanging fruit
provided by joe biden and nancy pelosi
little pdb in the squad on a near daily
basis
i mean i think this is kind of comedy
gold don't you
but it seems there's no hard feelings
because laura also had this to say i
like doing kate mckinnon doing me
because she's kind of fun right she's
very even-handed in her political humor
people say she doesn't make fun of the
other side i'm sure she does
wait they're telling me she doesn't it
was such a blast but someone not too
happy with their snl spoof is candace
owens martin luther king would have
voted for trump
hello to you too
lara liberals try to make everything
about race to quote the only words that
martin luther king ever said i have a
dream
that's it end of quote that's snl star
eggo nuodum parroting the political
commentator in the same sketch with kate
you know it's my greatest honor to
continue to fight for african americans
no matter how many times they asked me
to stop
thank you thank you candace
well candace saw the skit and shared her
thoughts on twitter posting a photo of
eggo as her and tagging the snl twitter
account she writes quote hey snl not
sure who this woman is you have playing
me but i am much better looking than
this adding next time just reach out and
i'll play myself that way the skit will
actually be funny and america might even
tune into the show again a couple hours
later eggo seemingly responded to
candace's tweet writing quote the irony
is that i'm actually a bad [ __ ]
for the record my name is eggo i can't
be bullied we can't tell you what's
going to be on air because we genuinely
don't know when e.t caught up with the
comedian and her snl castmate heidi
gardner ahead of the new season she said
it's ever-changing current events that
keep the show fresh so that always just
feels like added pressure but as far as
the news cycle keep the news coming
please we need ideas that's what keeps
the show on their
ideas abound via news so yeah i'm all
for a quick moving cycle
[Music]
you